j'arrête de boire entre mensuel comme
moi des connards est c'est marrant on y
prend goût c'est ce qui m'a dit topor
remis les redoutables lui maintiennent l
italie c'est mieux avec un coup devant
mener personnes osent le dire aussi si
je pense qu'il ya pas mal de gens comme
m6 au jeu qui ose dire ça non j'ai passé
la première fois j'entendais un mec me
dire ça à la télé je veux dire en public
et peut-être des gens qui le disent et
donc arrêter de fumer notamment des
gitanes j'ai arrêté de fumer est vital
moi aussi je trouve ça un peu fort
son faux videmment comme disait le
fameux serge toutes les cinq minutes
il arrête je n'avais pas s'égarer
d'arrêter de fumer
il est bon szpiner ouais moyens quoi
m'enfin c'est nous les petits pour tous
quoi tu t'es mis au pinard non non pas
particulièrement
enfin à partir de nos moyens d'habitude
ah ouais c'est par politesse strictement
par correction sinon je ne bois que de
l'eau
ah ouais c'est évident tu des france
patine originale à part dont ta bonne
mine
merci non je suis normal je bois du pin
un ou deux écartés ouais je connus
partie est identique
souvient eu en fait une mission sans
fallait trouver mon tatoo faut à chaque
fois
quoique quoique pas toujours et les
sorties il est sorti une semaine
quartier il a fait l'effet deux ans je
suis je signe un truc pour toi ouais
ouais ouais mais une pétition pour moi
j'en ai signé plat mais je savais pas
qu'il y ait un truc il avait deux ans
mais revenons chez koba c'est un vieux
classement c'est la cortisone qu'il a
fait deux ans de mandela comme il l'a
fait il a fait plus non je crois que ces
jeunes filles habillées par 18 les
quantités étaient beaucoup plus grosses
quantités n'étaient plus grosse et il
est noir c'est papa et wendel les
présidents le quota depuis je suis
président c'est bien il a viré sa ferme
et à l'humour mais là on tutoie raison
d'eux
deux ans je pense que tu pourrais faire
députée rosine par la voiture de
fonction par les noms là d'un dans la
voiture j'ai demandé s'ils avaient de la
dope en prison ce que ce dont je me
doute mais je vais savoir comment ça se
passait et il me racontait que les mecs
les trois premiers jours de la semaine
après le parloir
ils en ont tu vois et à partir du jeudi
matin le plus gourmand c'est dur mais je
pense qu'un peu partout
il a peu de raisons qu'il arrête mais me
disait par exemple que les mecs qui sont
accros à l'hérault les maths ensemble
sur le gars le patron de la prison comme
par hasard fait ces quartiers tu vois
mieux parce que après moi le problème
c'est que ils essayent de protéger
certains certes mais qu'après l'élection
de bâle 1-1
alors on n'est pas bon mais pas les
toxicos avec les braqueurs les braqueurs
en est avec les violeurs ouais c'est
comme un camp pénal on dirige into là tu
vois tu mets les belges ensemble et
hollandais ensemble doit non voilà c'est
à peu près ça c'est que c'est un camping
c'est plus ouvert que le camping ouest
et dans quels quartiers toi moi j'étais
quartier le broker d'abord je suis corse
c'est pour ça donc ça va en tout cas
thierry joulin c'est formidable que tu
t'organises ici une réunion de
délinquants absolument absolument non
par les sections pas en reste que ce
premier métier c'était mon premier tracé
et connaître ou de l'eau comme la balle
quoi c'est vrai quand tu as fait les
stinky toys était juste après la
délinquance
ouais parce que j'avais eu 13 mois avec
sursis je sais que je vais attaquer un
magasin car comme je savais pas ça j'ai
oublié le nom
ouais quelconque je vais fnac ou je ne
sais quoi et autres et du fait de sursis
bon bah tant pis je fais de la musique
ça fait 20 ans bientôt dix ans mais
c'est un bon travail de l'un comme ça
mais bien tu as pris vingt ans de
musique quoi ouais mais je me suis
jamais attaqué mois avec qui que ce soit
quoi parader des gros de gros truc
ouais amusant qui sont faits pour être
parent à quelqu'un
les banques n'ont pas les dons venant
surtout de la petite délinquance que des
trucs de petit con mais néanmoins
vachement rentable c'est un très très
bon inutile donc quand tu faisais des
stinky toys la rage était pas été pas
feinte
non non il n'y avait pas de côté pas une
cause ou une vraie rage est toujours la
même rage
je suis pas si on peut parler de rage de
rebellions --total sa tasse et a
rapporté du pognon amoureux solitaires
ouais ouais enfin c'est à dire que ça
mon à rapporter pas mal mais à partir du
moment où on n'y connait rien au pognon
ou ne sais pas le jir et c'est grâce à
mon a coûté dans le sens où bien entendu
on a le fiscaux qu après tout le fruit
reste ma direct whisstock même en
essayant d'être le plus honnête possible
avec les calvin de toute façon ça tourne
au vinaigre un peu ça tu peux pas savoir
que l'année d'après il y en a - et c'est
de façon moins au fil du bal jusqu'à dix
balles donc il dit brick by brick et
c'est pareil que quelle que soit la
somme fait qu évidemment ça même le
fourbi plutôt macho blagué ouais ouais
j'ai tout plaqué pour quoi où sont
toutes sortes de conneries en toutes
sortes de tony tu regrettes souvenons
moi j'ai une ire régnant dans
franchement
faut pas vraiment un peu j'ai fait j'ai
fait un nom de drogue ça je fonce à tout
à fait regrettable
tu prenais pas les rangs oui tout seul
humain à tous et puis évidemment en
ayant du fric certes moi j'ai jamais vu
dit leur jeu pratiqué ce jeu mais j'ai
vu deux dealers ils s'étaient boîte aux
lettres ces terrains en payant le prix
fort donc je faisais ça tout à fait en
douce si je puis dire m'a donc c'était
désastreux parce que c'est un petit
créatif machin donc après ces cliniques
monsieur vous avez sorti comme ça oui tu
as fait du sport non enfin ça dépend si
j'ai fait du sport parce que j'avais
j'avais acheté une maison en bretagne
et donc j'ai fait du hamac après pendant
deux mois qu'on peut dire que c'est une
forme de sport assez le table et sauvage
ni à toi ce piano ouais ouais enfin de
jouer un truc puisque je te fais ce que
tu veux mais le problème c'est que moi
je suis pas jouer du piano mais tu dois
jouer tu peux je m'en sers pour faire
des breaks dans le suisse et le faire au
foot ou chômeurs non arrête tes
conneries non pas c'est un truc de
guitare aussi bizarre beaux arts alors
rectangle c'est un truc de guitare donc
transcription cette rue
c'est un truc de guitare tu vas où je
vais rajouter une trois notes chez
puisque c'était gens mais il ya plein
d'accord derrière quoi c'est ça le
problème
bon alors si nous pouvons parler c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
g
un peu
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas d'où ils viennent et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de l'ina
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus